The Joe Rogan experience. Did you
see a, I thought Vinny Magalhaes.
She's got to take it that last I did too.
I remember seeing a lot.
He's really coming into his own.
His striking is caught up with
a lot of his grapple. Oh yeah.
And he's fantastic after this back.
Very dangerous.
I've never seen a guy that big bath
flexible. He can do everything.
When it comes to Jujitsu. Do you ever
see when the flying armbar paid upon? No.
Nope. It's crazy. Look, who the fuck does
that? Nope. I was at that match. The, uh,
the Metamorris, I think it was a
w w was it? Metamorris when he,
what'd he grappled Keenan?
Was that Metamorris few years back?
Maybe like four or five years. Yeah.
It could have been metamorris or,
but it was clue.
Metamorris matchups had some good ones,
but I forget all the matchups. Yeah,
those are good events, huh? Yes. Yeah. No
more. Huh? I wish there was more of those,
man.
I mean,
I'm happy Eddie Bravo's sort of taken
over that space with the Ebi and a combat.
You just who now have you seen
that slaps her so sick, man,
it's so six great idea.
It's nice.
It's a great idea at times
like you might be holding on,
but that's slap that might cause
the guy to let go of something.
Changes the game.
There's things aren't available anymore.
You can't just allow yourself. It's just
too hard. You could somebody like, oh,
somebody stopped, somebody whacked the
roadshow. Stop. Somebody's got on top,
mounted them and just blasted
them with pumps. Their head. Yeah.
It was pretty rough, man. It's
like you, it's almost like,
am I going to look at that?
I mean you can do ground and pound and
we learned from boss route and way back
in the Pancrase days. Do you
remember those days? Yeah.
Boss route and figured out how to pull
his hand back way further than other
people and boss route and would
smash guys with palm strikes.
He was throwing like upper cuts and hooks,
like he wasn't just like [inaudible].
Yeah. This, these are really high
level Jujitsu to with smacks.
Look at home. What? Ugh. Yeah. I need all
that guy's not used to getting slapped up,
not by a guy with a nasty
guard like Wagner roadshow.
Ah, yeah. If he wants to tap,
his nose is fucked up. Goodness.
Yeah. Can you tap from the slap? Yeah,
you can tab. Oh, he's getting
beat up the reputation.
Stop Mike Bell Tron seen enough.
See,
once he starts dropping those
palms down, boy. Huh? Paul, Huh?
Yeah, it's a forehead. It's
a reality check. You know,
it's a reality check about how
dangerous this position is.
You can't really just sit and let a guy
mount you do something desperate to get
out of that. But in Jujitsu,
if the guy's just mounting you,
you can kind of chill out,
chilling out,
figuring out how to escape a leg
or something. That shit. Yeah.
Combat you just so you gotta
get the fuck out of there.
That's a terrible place to be. Yeah. Same.
They were like MMA, right? Being mounted.
So especially when you're tired.
Well,
the difference between MMA grappling and
regular grappling to used to always be
with the, one of the big ones, at
least I should say, was leg locks.
They thought you really couldn't get
away with leg locks in as much in MMA
because as you're going for the legs,
you have two arms committed to the legs.
So I'm just going to punch you in the
face and you don't have defense for it.
But now you're seeing when God's like m
and Ra bursts on the scene and started
ripping guys knees apart,
you see how effective that is.
And then Paul Horez people, no, no,
you don't like, like less scared of it.
It's they're scary, Huh? Yeah.
I've actually so infatuated Cabrini
operations and to reconstructions. Ah,
but are you like, do you like
to watch? Oh yeah, yeah. Like,
yeah, John Danaher. Yeah,
dude, he's so interesting.
[inaudible] you know? Yeah, yeah.
I remember just like kind of looking
into the little bitty Cummings. Yeah.
Those guys are savages. Gary, Tony,
fucking people's legs up and you know,
and then Craig Jones and all these other
guys that are coming from all over the
world that are leg locks specialists now,
they all have these
complex leg locks systems.
Now it's a totally different
thing. Holy Shit. You fuck up?
You go zig when he should
have zagged. Like when Brian
Hall fought Bj Penn. Right.
And he caught him in that. I was
like, no, no, no, not that way. Yeah,
you just try to get out. He tried to get
out and Ryan Hall just locked it up. Oh,
I just imagined the field right
now. I always tap road. Oh,
well it's once that stuff gets chewed up
inside there, that's the problem. I mean,
some people could just take it,
but once you start ripping
meniscus apart and cartilage apart,
once that stuff starts happening,
ligaments starts getting stretched out
and rip a little bit and there are always
going to be wiggly. I mean, even Gordon
ride just ripped his fucking leg apart.
Did he really? Yeah. Yeah.
He just had surgery. Um,
I think he did it in an actual
grappling match that I think his foot,
his leg moved weird and it just,
it popped his, his knee apart.
But the guy had a hold on
it. I don't think so. No, no,
I think it was in a scramble. I think
it came apart in a scramble. Um,
but there's a lot of those leg lock
experts right now that scare the shit out
and everything came from dean lister,
which is crazy.
[inaudible] you know the story?
No,
John Danaher was talking
to Dean lister and uh,
Dean lister was talking about leg
locks and John Donna her said something
inquired about why you do leg locks.
And he goes,
why would you ignore 50% of the body?
And John Don heart being a fucking crazy
wizards. And he is like, why would you,
why would you,
there's all these means there's a fucking
hilarious meme of John Donna her in
bed next to a woman and it says,
why would you ignore 40% 50% of the body?
Oh Man. Yeah. And then other guys. Yeah.
Well, Don, hers,
a guy who understands things like he
sees them on a very complex level,
like he understands all the various
possible exchanges and what's the best way
to mitigate, like stop the defense,
push the offense, control the situation.
What is, what is the ultimate
control position I have to get to?
Do I have to get on the inside? Do I grab
it this way? Do I grab it? And then they,
once they started really experimenting
and putting it together and putting it
into a system,
and you see how these guys who have
only been doing Jujitsu for a few years,
like Nicky Ryan and Gordon,
right?
They start tapping all these like
really legit guys. They're like,
what the fuck is happening? Yeah. The
systems are craving Kamora system.
Everything. Huh? [inaudible] I
think that helps a lot. It just,
when it comes to training, learning
things in systems, you know what I mean?
I think 10 plan, it has like their
own short system right now for sure.
And it helps. It helps you go to
another state. Like it's the same. Yeah.
Same System, right? Yeah. All
systems help. Yeah. You know? I mean,
and then fighters devise their
own system really often, you know,
have their own entries in their
own ways of defending things. Yeah.